we got the fellas a CNC all right now I
see all coordinated in black
looking sharp how much one is it for you
guys to put looks together as a group as
one unified boyband
it's extremely more Street but this time
I think we kind of mix it together so
yeah we're happy about how it came out
it's reflecting each of your individual
styles to the laminated tonight to
celebrate tonight
you guys have had an incredible career
since you guys broke out what has that
journey been like it's been amazing it's
been a blessing out of everything we're
so happy we're so thankful for
everything that the fans always are
doing for us and yeah with the new EP is
crazy right now the Coquina somos CP has
been amazing all over the places they're
talking about and also we are on Mateo a
mobile logo so it's gonna be a super
dope performance that we've never done
before it says cool are you guys more
nervous for your categories or for the
performance tonight Marc Anthony they're
recognizing it tonight you guys have a
favorite song from the keaghlan salsa
come on the spiders
I got I know you guys got running a
quick question for the fans because the
last time we spoke to you you're all
singles that's still the case y'all so
stage man still singer you know waiting
for that go to to find it all for us to
find each other you know yeah so you had
some chemistry with Amelia and a music
video bro that [ __ ] back I'm getting the
rap you guys got ahead inside good luck
to you okay
good luck tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]